- I have to say one thing.
The biggest challenge for me
was, in all of our singing,
Will and I for some
reason were face to face.
Like, they couldn't have us
just facing different directions.
We were face to face.
You try singing for like
three weeks straight
while staring at Will
Ferrell, who's like...
(audience applauding)
He's holding his ear for no
reason, and I would hit a note
and he'd look at me and go, "No."
(audience laughs)
"Again!"
- "Better! Better!"
- Yeah.
So brutal!
- So funny!
- You can actually hear
me laughing on the tracks,
I'm sure now.
Holding it back.
- You're all so wonderful in it,
and you pull it off and you
sound amazing and look amazing.
It's very, yeah.
(audience cheering)
The best!